>> WOMEN ARE ENSLAVED AND WE
HAVE NO RIGHTS AND NO FREEDOMS.
FORCED BY AN OPPRESSIVE
GOVERNMENT TO BEAR CHILDREN
UNDER PENALTY IS DEATH.
MY NAME IS OFF RED AND I INTEND
TO SURVIVE.
>> BLESSED BE.
>> MAY THE LORD.
>> I HAVE NEWS.
THERE IS A RESISTANCE FORMING.
WE COULD JOIN THEM.
>> IT'S TOO DANGEROUS.
>> SHH.
SOMEONE IS COMING.
>> HEY, WHAT'S UP.
>> ASH, JEN.
WHAT THE FRICK IS UP?
>> IT'S MY CINCO DE MAYO HALF
BIRTHDAY.
>> DO YOU NOT KNOW?
IT'S THE REPUBLIC.
IT'S DIFFERENT NOW.
WE ARE HAND MAIDS.
THE GOVERNMENT SUBJUGATED THE
WOMEN.
THEY TOOK OUR MONEY AND OUR JOBS
AND OUR KIDS.
>> OH!
>> OH, YEAH.
>> THE GUYS READ SOMETHING ABOUT
THAT.
SUPER BUSY WITH WORK LATELY.
>> PLEASE LEAVE US.
>> THEY'RE SEE US TALKING TO
YOU, WE WILL BE PUNISHED.
>> THAT SUCKED.
YOU GUYS SHOULD FIGHT BACK.
>> MY DAD IS A LAWYER.
HE COULD HELP YOU.
HE MOSTLY DOES ENTERTAINMENT
LAW.
>> WE CAN'T.
>> SORRY FOR HELPING.
>> WE NEED TO GO.
>> HER NAME IS ASH.
>> NO, IT'S OF DANIEL.
I'M HIS PROPERTY NOW.
>> DANIEL IS LIKE SUPER
CONSERVATIVE NOW.
YOU SHOULD LEAVE.
>> YEAH, I CAN'T.
>> HEY, YES, YOU CAN.
>> BRO, DANIEL.
>> NO WAY!
>> THE GIRLS SQUAD.
J TOWN.
WHAT'S DIFFERENT ABOUT YOU.
>> I DON'T KNOW IF YOU HEARD
ABOUT THIS THING WITH THE WOMEN.
IT SUCKS.
>> YEAH, I HEARD SOMETHING ABOUT
THAT.
I DIDN'T KNOW IF IT WAS FOR SURE
HAPPENING.
IS THERE A PROTEST?
>> SEVERAL YEARS AGO.
>> I MEANT TO GO TO THAT.
>> OH, NO.
IT'S TOO LATE.
THEY FOUND US.
>> GIRLS SQUAD!
ASH, WHERE YOU BEEN?
YOU MISSED PEACE IN THE PARK.
THIS IS GOING TO SOUND AWKWARD,
BUT I HAVE TO TAKE YOU TO THE
GOVERNMENT TO TORTURE YOU, BUT
AFTER THAT WE'RE GOING TO PLAY.
YOU ALL SHOULD COME THROUGH.
>> HOW MUCH YOU TOP THE BED THEY
DON'T EVEN COME.
>> THE HAND MAID'S TALE.
>> SEE, NETFLIX, WE HAVE ONE
TOO!